oh the ComicCon flood has started so
word news trailers stuff has started
flooding out of Comic Con as it always
does I don't know how many videos I'm
going to make about stuff coming out of
Comic Con I'm going to try and keep it
to as few as I possibly can because I
want whatever videos I make to be made
pretty quickly and turned around and put
available and I don't want to flood you
guys with like three videos in a day I
don't want to do that to you I don't
think anybody needs that much of me but
I also don't have the subscriber base
yet to have the thing oh well they'll
wait for my opinion they'll wait three
four days I mean the channel is going
nicely appreciate it but I'm not there
yet anyway that's enough preamble let's
start by talking about DC and what
they've got going now there might be
additional DC announcements that are
happening as I record this but for right
now we've got some word on some titles
some confirmed projects and a new
Justice League trailer so why don't we
start with that um
I don't hate it which that might sign it
sound like you know back in a compliment
but for me if you've seen my reaction to
the first trailer that's a big step up
there's not a ton that I love about it
there's a lot of things that I'm like oh
that's nice about it and there are way
fewer things that I'm like oh I hate
that so on balance a much better trailer
unquestionably and it's very obvious
that at this point Warner Brothers
marketing if not Warner Brothers as a
whole as an organization seem to have a
better understanding about where the
good will still remains for their
properties because I mean it opens with
what looks like a heist which I mean you
can't help but think of the opening to
the Dark Knight a little bit and then we
start with Wonder Woman who is the hero
in the back standing in the public eye
right now so we get plenty of her that's
not a huge shock they kind of want to
ride her momentum and hope that it
continues to build
additionally anticipation for a movie
that I think more audiences were
skeptical about then a lot of people
want to admit but that's a smart thing
to do Bank on the one who is everyone's
like yeah that was great Bank on her
that's a smart thing I'd like to the
point is actually so the shows that
mascara looks like Stefan was actually
stealing something from the Amazon then
we get kind of our first not really
first glimpse because the ad has deleted
scene in a BBS but um we get you know
some additional looks room I can't just
call right now they're not going to call
him by the actual character name because
audiences are going to laugh if somebody
actually said Steppenwolf and is
expected to take this guy seriously but
we get a little bit to him we a little
bits of what I assume is his voice and
that actually laid out what I think was
a really interesting angle and one I
hadn't thought about it and one that
also kind of elevates my hope Orton I
didn't have hope but might build a
little interest in the premise on this
because what what we knew about this
film coming in was that it was basically
going to be a MacGuffin hunt which I
don't want to accuse DC of ripping off
Marvel because they've been doing their
own thing I don't think it's been
working but they have been doing their
own thing but you know the MacGuffin
hunt has kind of been Marvel's thing
with the Infinity stones and it a lot of
the premise of the same fella was going
to be the same thing with the mother box
here but there's a there's a wrinkle
that they've added which helps and you
get that from Steppenwolf voiceover he
says there's no Guardians here
no lanterns and no Kryptonian so I like
the idea that he's coming now having
watched and observed the earth and it's
thinking now is when they're weak I like
that because it immediately puts the
heroes on a proper defensive because but
there's something to me I I get really
taken in by a villain who truly does not
consider the heroes to be a threat like
not even like oh I didn't know they were
like he's fully aware that they're here
he just doesn't care he doesn't think
they have a chance I like that in a
villain so that that is a nice angle I'm
enjoying that there's
more bits of humor in this and more bits
of humor that at least for me worth they
felt less crowbarred in they felt less
cringy except for the closing joke that
one he I mean you know kind of acute
observation but that one felt a little
cringy but the mother was like what
flash has lined like I'm not ready for
battle I just push people and run away
like I actually kind of really loved
that as an assessment of flashes power
set and if they're making him the young
one in the group I like how trepidatious
he is and I also like that kind of
moment where Wonder Woman's sword is
falling she jumps after and he comes
around and basically just kind of holds
the tip with his finger meaning he stops
it falling so she'll catch up to it I
like the idea that flash doesn't even
necessarily to learn how to fight like
in a punching people sense but just
learns how to use his powers to in a
fairly you know non confrontational way
but that will still help
I love Alfred German Erin's has a great
sense of dry witness that I'm really
looking forward to getting some more of
there was not nearly as much CGI
overload in this one as there was in the
first trailer there are still bits of it
though like the Aquaman like slamming
the eye through the building and then
jumping on the rubble and the whole sky
is random like that's oh that's a lot of
CGI so it's still there but at least as
far as those trailer goes they didn't
load the trailer with all the excessive
CGI stuff which I think was a smart
thing to do Aquaman still not sold on
him I was kind of getting there like
maybe this could work and then he said
oh yeah or something and I was like no
no and there was another thing that I
think was interesting in terms of the
voice-over talking about Superman it
feels like they are going to act going
forward and if Superman had been
portrayed the way a lot of people as
they wished he was as opposed to the way
he actually was because there's all this
talk about how Superman was a beacon of
hope that he brought the best out of
people and I'm just thinking back like
that's how I think of Superman in the
comics when he's written well I'm
thinking back to Man of Steel especially
BBS not the words I want to use to
describe him but I there's something I
gotta appreciate the audacity of base
we going look we're just going to act
like we did it right previously let's
let's just go on that assumption and
move forward then they kind of hinted
Superman's return at the end between
Alfred yo seeing somebody want to see
and saying all and neo implying that
somebody who hadn't seen is now joining
and I mean that's not a shock but it's
kind of fun for people who aren't like
me and I assume most of my viewers who
are who know for certain that Superman
is coming back because we follow the
marketing material everything else so we
already know and we have known for a
while but maybe for general audiences
they don't already know so that's a fun
hint and it might get them thinking a
little bit more so you know not horribly
handled I have a suspicion that there's
probably going to be some people doing
reactions to this that are going to try
and break down what is inserted by Joss
Whedon and what is remaining from
Schneider I don't want to play that game
I want to go in and try and experience
the movie as a thing unto itself but not
parse out oh well that's from this
that's from this that's from this I want
to try and take it as a whole and as a
result I'm not going to do anything like
that but I suspect there's going to be a
lot of people who are going to be
pointing to humor and calling it we ness
core whatever I mean probably know those
jokes were already in there and unless
Warner Brothers releases a breakdown of
exactly what was reshot and what was
handled under Whedon we're not going to
know and they're not going to do that so
I think that's a pointless exercise but
so far the blend seems to be going
better than I would have thought I'm so
I turned around I'm not I'm still not a
farm girl and I'm definitely going to
see it but you know what better is
better and this trailer is better than
the last one and it sells a it sells an
angle that is more interesting to me
than honestly I couldn't have told you
anything about what the story was from
that first trailer so that wasn't I
don't really know what that one was
selling me this starts selling me on a
story and a setup and a world that well
I'm not enthusiastic about I'm also not
going oh that's awful so baby steps
improvement a marked improvement from
the last one look guys I'll be blunt
some people are going to call this
spiteful the fact that I'm still going
I'm not sure if I'm going to see it I
don't want to get my hopes up and
suffer again that's what I don't want so
you know what you can call me bitter you
can call me a Marvel fanboy but a big
chunk of my trepidation for this is I am
genuinely afraid to get my hopes up
because I'm afraid of going in and
getting exactly of what I was afraid I
was going to get the last time I talked
about this movie so let's talk about the
other little bit because they've
announced a few pieces of information in
terms of later films they've confirmed
the Wonder Woman sequel they could
they've reconfirmed that Green Lantern
Corps is happening you know Suicide
Squad stuff that I'd say and some things
relate to that I think the one a lot of
people are going to focus on though is
the title for the flash film flash point
I know I said in previous videos other
than she's just do flash point you use
it to fix their universe
I think we're brothers would actually do
it and to be fair they might not but
given that they have said outright they
are trying to re-examine and retool the
approach that they've had to these
movies in these characters the fact that
Zack Snyder who had been a massive
creative guiding force has now gone from
the thing and it is now looking
increasingly like Ben Affleck might not
stick around even for his own solo
Batman movie for whatever reason like if
they're going to retool it that's a
great way to do it without having to
reboot everything I mean that's using
Flash's movie to do the flashpoint story
to be able to account for things like
recasting Batman or retconning pieces of
the history that they that they set up
but don't want to deal with anymore
that's not an awful idea you got they if
they do actually do that and I if
they're not using flashpoint as a way to
actually retool this universe I hope
they realize that that's what everyone
is going to be expecting them to do so I
hope they really is what they got into
by naming it that if that's not what
they're doing but I want assume it's
what they're doing so I just hope that
they understand going in that what the
movie can't be is nothing but a retool
job they're still going to have to tell
a story in the heart of the thing itself
and honestly with Barry appearing as
young and having had as few adventures
as we'll have seen I think they have the
chance to do flashpoint Titan
eriell better than the TV show did it
because by the time the TV show did the
whole you know berry saves his mother
and causes a mess thing that thing had
already been going for a couple of
seasons and by the time he did that was
like berry you should know better so if
we do that story again with a younger
berry who hasn't been doing as much who
does not know better the story might
actually work this time in terms of
adaptation they because the original
story works pretty well for what it was
it was hard to get invested in because
you knew it was going to be temporary
and everything was going to be reset for
new 52 but as the substance thing
contained story it was pretty good and
there's there's enough to be mined there
and I think they could actually do some
interesting things in terms of giving us
an alternate reality for what we've
already seen basically she knew the
cynical part in me says they can
basically go oh you thought we did it
bad before look how much worse we could
have done it okay now here we fixed it
that's and that's a very cool very
cynical way to put it but you know I'll
be interested to see how much darker the
world can test for flashpoint and then
you know what changes get implemented I
think the obvious one would be to take
that opportunity to recast Batman
because you'll have the excuse for
things are just different now so we will
see we'll see what goes on with all of
this I am in a better place with DC than
I've been in a while because honestly
since my very angry ramps like back in I
don't know March since I did that most
of what has come out of DC has been
decent to inoffensive um a couple of
tiny exceptions but it's not stuff I
exceptionally care about it seems like
overall they are getting much more
cautious because they really went into
this DC EU thing off the back of Man of
Steel like a bull in a china shop they
were just we're going to charge ahead no
matter what and I think they have
realized that that might not have been
the way to go about him so I think there
being much more measured in their
approach to
projects they're doing and how they're
doing them than they were previously and
that is all good stuff there may even
come today when I genuinely enjoy DC
movies again that would be very nice so
those are my thoughts on the Justice
League trailer and the announcements in
terms of future films specifically
focusing on flashpoint what are your
thoughts on this are you keeping track
of what's coming out of comic-con or you
just keep your head down to the
weekend's over so you can deal it all
with it later whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listening to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]